have you ever watched a baby learning to
crawl because there's any parent knows
it's gripping first they wiggle about on
the floor usually backwards but then
they drag themselves forwards and then
they pull themselves up to stand and we
all clap and that's simple motion of
forwards and upwards it's the most basic
direction of progress we humans
recognize we tell it in our story of
evolution as well from our lolloping
ancestors to Homo erectus finally up
right to Homo sapiens depicted was a man
always mid stride so no wonder we so
readily believe that economic progress
will take this very same shape this ever
rising line of growth it's time to think
again to reimagine the shape of progress
because today we have economies that
need to grow whether or not they make us
rise and what we need especially in the
richest countries our economies that
make us thrive whether or not they grow
yes it's a little flippin words hiding a
profound shift in mindset but I believe
this is the shift we need to make if we
Humanity are going to thrive here
together this century so where did this
obsession with growth come from well GDP
gross domestic product it's just the
total cost of goods and services sold in
an economy in a year it was invented in
the 1930s but it very soon became the
overriding goal of policy making so much
so that even today in the richest of
countries governments think that the
solution to their economic problems lies
in more growth just how that happened is
best hold through the 1960 classic by w
w roscoe i love it so much i have a
first edition copy
the stages of economic growth a
non-communist manifesto you can just
smell the politics and and Rosco tells
us that all economies need to pass
through five stages of growth first
traditional Society where a nation's
output is limited by its technology its
institutions and mindset but then the
preconditions for takeoff where we get
the beginnings of a banking industry the
mechanization of work and the belief
that growth is necessary for something
beyond itself like national dignity or a
better life for the children then take
off where compound interest is built
into the economies institutions and
growth becomes the normal condition
fourth is the drive to maturity where
you can have any industry you want no
matter your natural resource base and
the fifth and final stage the age of
high mass consumption where people can
buy all the consumer goods they want
like bicycles and sewing machines this
was 1960 remember well you can hear the
implicit airplane metaphor in this story
but this plane is like no other because
it can never be allowed to land roster
left us flying into the sunset of mass
consumerism and he knew it as he wrote
and then the question beyond where
history offers us only fragments what to
do when the increase in real income
itself loses its charm he asked that
question but he never answered it and
here's why the year was 1960 he was an
advisor to the presidential candidate
John F Kennedy who was running for
election on the promise of 5% growth so
Rostow's job is to keep that plane
flying not to ask if how or when it
could ever be allowed to land so here we
are flying into the sunset of mass
consumerism over half a century on with
economies that have come to expect
demand and
hand upon unending growth because we're
financially politically and socially
addicted to it we're financially
addicted to growth because today's
financial system is designed to pursue
the highest rate of monetary return
putting publicly traded companies under
constant pressure to deliver growing
sales growing market share and growing
profits because banks create money as
debt baring interest which must be
repaid with more with politically
addicted to growth because politicians
want to raise tax revenue without
raising taxes and a growing GDP seems a
sure way to do that and no politician
wants to lose their place in the g20
family photo but if their economy stops
growing while the rest keep going will
they'll be booted out by the next
emerging powerhouse and we are socially
addicted to growth because thanks to a
century of consumer propaganda which
fascinatingly was created by Edward
Bernays the nephew of Sigmund Freud who
realized that his uncle psychotherapy
could be turned into very lucrative
retail therapy if we could be convinced
to believe that we transform ourselves
every time we buy something more
none of these addictions are
insurmountable but they all deserve far
more attention than they currently get
because look where this journeys been
taking us global GDP is 10 times bigger
than it was in 1950 and that increase
has brought prosperity to billions of
people but the global economy has also
become incredibly divisive with the vast
share of returns to wealth now accruing
to a fraction of the global 1% and the
economy has become incredibly
degenerative rapidly destabilizing this
delicately balanced planet on which all
of our lives depend ippolit issues know
it and so they offer new destinations
for growth you can have green growth
inclusive growth smart resilient
balanced growth choose any future you
want so long as you choose growth I
think it's time to choose a higher
ambition
a far bigger one
because humanity's 21st century
challenge is clear to meet the needs of
all people within the means of this
extraordinary unique living planet so
that we and the rest of nature can
thrive progress on this goal isn't going
to be measured with the metric of money
we need a dashboard of indicators and
when I sat down to try and draw a
picture of what that might look like
strange though this is going to sound it
came out looking like a doughnut I know
I'm sorry
but let me introduce you to the one
doughnut that might actually turn out to
be good for us
so imagine humanity's resource use
radiating out from the middle that hole
in the middle is a place where people
are falling short on life's essentials
they don't have the food health care
education political voice housing that
every person needs for life of dignity
and opportunity we want to get everybody
out of the hole over the social
foundation and into that green doughnut
itself but and it's a big but we cannot
let our collective resource use
overshoot that outer circle the
ecological ceiling because there we put
so much pressure who this extraordinary
planet that we begin to kick it out of
kilter we caused climate breakdown we
certify the oceans a hole in the ozone
layer pushing ourselves beyond the
planetary boundaries of the life
supporting systems that have for the
last 11 thousand years made earth such a
benevolent home to humanity so this
double-sided challenge to meet the needs
of all within the means of the planet
that invites a new shape of progress no
longer this ever rising line of growth
but a sweet spot for humanity thriving
in dynamic balance between the
foundation and a ceiling and I was
really struck once I drawn this picture
to realize that the symbol of well-being
in many ancient cultures reflects this
very same sense of dynamic balance from
the marrow ritika Rangi to the taoist
yin yang the buddhist endless knot the
Celtic double spiral so can we find this
dynamic balance in the 21st century well
that's a key
question because as these red wedges
show right now we are far from balanced
falling short and overshooting at the
same time look in that hole and you can
see that millions or billions of people
worldwide still fall short on their most
basic of needs and yet we've already
overshot at least four of these
planetary boundaries risking
irreversible impacts of climate
breakdown and ecosystem collapse this is
the state of humanity and our planetary
home we the people of the early 21st
century this is our selfie no economist
from last century saw this picture so
why would we imagine that their theories
would be up for taking on its challenges
we need ideas of our own because we are
the first generation to see this and
probably the last with a real chance of
turning the story around you see 20th
century economics assured us that if
growth creates inequality don't try to
redistribute because more growth will
even things up again
if growth creates pollution don't try to
regulate because more growth will clean
things up again except it turns out it
doesn't and it won't we need to create
economies that tackle this shortfall and
overshoot together by design we need
economies that are regenerative and
distributive by design you see we've
inherited degenerative industries we
take us materials make them into stuff
we want use it for a while often only
once and then throw it away and that is
pushing us over planetary boundaries so
we need to bend those arrows around
create economies that work with and
within the cycles of the living world so
that resources are never used up but it
used again and again economies that run
on sunlight where waste from one process
is food for the next and this kind of
regenerative design is popping up
everywhere over hundred cities worldwide
from Quito to Oslo from Harare to Hobart
already generate more than 70% of their
electricity from Sun wind and waves
cities like London Glasgow Amsterdam are
pioneering circular city design
finding ways to turn the waste from one
over
process into food for the next and from
tigre ethiopia to queensland australia
farmers and foresters are regenerating
once barren landscapes so added teams
with life again but as well as being
regenerative by design our economies
must be distributive by design and we've
got unprecedented opportunities for
making that happen because 20th century
centralized technologies institutions
can concentrated wealth knowledge and
power in few hands this century we can
design our technologies and institutions
to distribute wealth knowledge and
empowerment to many instead of fossil
fuel energy and large-scale
manufacturing we've got renewable energy
networks digital platforms and 3d
printing 200 years of corporate
controller the intellectual property is
being upended by the bottom-up opens
sauce peer-to-peer knowledge Commons and
corporations that still pursue maximum
rate of return for their shareholders
well he suddenly looked rather
out-of-date next to social enterprises
there's designs to generate multiple
forms of value and share it with those
throughout their networks if we can
harness today's technologies from AI to
blockchain to the Internet of Things to
material science if we can harness these
in service of distributive design we can
ensure that healthcare education finance
energy political voice reaches and
empowers those people who need it most
you see regenerative and distributive
design create extraordinary
opportunities for the 21st century
economy so where does this leave Rosco's
airplane ride well for some it still
carries the hope of endless green growth
the idea that thanks to
dematerialization exponential GDP growth
can go on forever
while resource use keeps falling but
look at the data this is a flight of
fancy yes we need to dematerialize our
economies but this dependency on
unending growth cannot be decoupled from
resource use on anything like the scale
required
to bring us safely back within planetary
boundaries I know this way of thinking
about growth is unfamiliar because
growth is good no we want our children
to grow our gardens to grow yes look to
nature and growth is a wonderful healthy
source of life it's a phase but many
economies like Ethiopia and Nepal today
may be in that phase their economies are
growing at 7% a year but look again to
nature because from your children's feet
to the Amazon forest nothing in nature
grows forever things grow and they grow
up and they mature and it's only by
doing so that they can thrive for a very
long time we already know this if I told
you my friend went to the doctor who
told her she had a growth well that
feels very different because we
intuitively understand that when
something tries to grow forever within a
healthy living thriving system it's a
threat to the health of the whole so why
would we imagine that our economies
would be the one system that could buck
this trend and succeed by growing
forever we urgently need financial
political and social innovations that
enable us to overcome this structural
dependency on growth so that we can
instead focus on thriving in balance
within the social and the ecological
boundaries of the donut and if the mere
idea of boundaries makes you feel well
bounded I think again because the
world's most ingenious people turn
boundaries into the source of their
creativity from Mozart on his five
octave piano Jimi Hendrix on his six
string guitar Serena Williams on a
tennis court its boundaries that unleash
our potential and the donuts boundaries
unleash the potential for humanity to
thrive with boundless creativity but
it's a patient belonging and meaning
it's going to take
all the ingenuity that we have got to
get there so bring it on thank you
[Applause]
[Music]